Hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with the brief information for today, Tuesday
, May 11, starting today
you will be able to attend the tax station to
receive the coronavirus vaccine
from the comfort of your vehicle.
I hear the injection will be given through the
window at the  parking lot on
property vaccine available on
site will be fighter and you can receive
both doses following this same
procedure instead will be open
7am to noon for the
next six weeks make sure to make
an appointment
south health district  nevada
works on incentives for more
people in the community to get
the coronavirus vaccine however
this will depend on federal aid
meanwhile a new
cure site will open in the
mall what if you attend this you will be
entered to win a card  as a
gift this clinic is open from Tuesday to
Friday from 8 in the morning to 2 in the
afternoon throughout the  mes
en riverside announced that the
payment for parking will return this begins
with a special event as it coincides
with the playoffs of the gas
golden knights team starting on
June 1st the payment for
public parking and ballet will begin but
there is good news for the locals already
that they will be able to use the parking lot
for free for the first three
hours it is also completely free
for some people with
company membership now we pass with
the weather forecast a
sunny day with temperatures around the 90s is
expected tomorrow temperatures will start to rise
until  on Friday so
drink a lot of water and be careful, have a
good day I am Sal and Jaramillo with your
brief information for them USA in
Spanish